Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Surfshark
VPN.
Luego os doy más detalles pero antes, vamos
con nuestra historia de hoy
…
Os voy a hacer una pregunta…
¿Por qué Rusia es tan grande?
Vale, ya lo sé… seguramente nunca os lo
habíais preguntado.
Pero pensadlo bien: hablamos del país más
grande del mundo, con nada menos que 9 zonas
horarias distintas.
Hablamos además de un país donde conviven
decenas de culturas distintas.
Por ejemplo, todos sabéis que la religión
mayoritaria en Rusia es el Cristianismo Ortodoxo.
Sin embargo, Rusia tiene regiones enteras
de mayoría budista o musulmana.
Y la pregunta es ¿Cómo han llegado hasta
aquí?
¿Fue Rusia siempre tan grande?
Como os podéis imaginar, la historia de Rusia
está llena de grandes conquistas y… sí,
colonialismo.
Podríamos decir que Rusia ha sido un gran
imperio colonial.
Aunque la pregunta que nos hacemos en el vídeo
de hoy es…
¿Y si Rusia siguiera siendo un imperio colonial?
Dicho de otra forma ¿Hasta qué punto la
invasión de Putin en Ucrania no es más que
un intento de evitar que Ucrania se independice?
¡Tranquilos!
Sé que muchos estaréis removiéndoos en
la silla.
Y ya os aviso que el vídeo de hoy va a ser
especialmente polémico.
Muy polémico.
Y diréis ¿por qué?
Pues porque fue precisamente la Unión Soviética
quien más criticó los imperios coloniales
europeos.
Fue la Unión Soviética quién creó el comité
de descolonización en la ONU.
Y es la Rusia actual quien protesta cada vez
que Estados Unidos abre una base militar en
otro país.
Sin embargo, la historia de Rusia tiene demasiadas
cosas en común con las de cualquier otro
imperio colonial.
De hecho, el ex presidente checo, Vaclav Havel
llegó a resumir la historia de Rusia con
estas palabras.
Atentos.
(“El problema de Rusia es que no sabe dónde
empieza y todo termina” –Vaclav Havel,
ex presidente Checo)
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es
¿Hasta qué punto la Unión Soviética fue
un imperio colonial como lo fue el Imperio
Español, el Británico o el Francés?
¿Siguen existiendo colonias rusas?
¿Podríamos decir que Ucrania es una colonia
rusa que quiere independizarse?
Porque hoy, vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes… antes vamos a ver
cómo evitar que colonicen tu móvil o tu
ordenador ¡Si amigos de VisualPolitik!
Este es el momento en el que os vamos a contar
como navegar por Internet de forma segura…
y como podéis ver páginas de cualquier parte
del mundo.
Muchos ya sabéis la respuesta: SURFSHARK
VPN.
Y, creedme, el tema de la ciberseguridad se
lo toman en serio.
Por ejemplo, Surfshark tiene una herramienta
que se llama CLEANWEB que bloquea todos los
popups de propaganda, por donde se cuelan
más bots y cookies que no queremos tener.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, con una misma
cuenta de Surfshark podrás registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras ¿Quieres navegar
con seguridad desde tu SmartTV?
¿Desde tu móvil?
¿Desde tu ordenador?
Puedes hacer todo esto con la misma cuenta
de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos una oferta especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Si utilizáis el código POLITIK podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento más 3 meses
extra totalmente gratuitos.
Tenéis el link en la descripción.
No esperéis más y descargaros ya la aplicación.
(LA ERA DE LA DESCOLONIZACIÓN)
Voy a haceros una pregunta ¿Son las islas
Canarias una colonia española?
¡Ya lo sé!
Muchos de los españoles que veáis este vídeo
os sentiréis ofendidos.
Pero, creedme, fuera de España no todo el
mundo lo tiene claro.
Atentos.
(El País 17-06-2009: Canarias y Baleares,
colonias según 'Newsweek')
Y diréis ¿Entonces…
tanto las Islas Canarias como las Islas Baleares
están consideradas como…
colonias es España?
¿En serio?
¡Tranquilos!
Ahora lo vamos a explicar.
Pero antes, tenemos que entender qué es la
descolonización.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 1945,
más de un tercio de la población vivía
en territorios colonizados por una metrópoli
¡Habéis oído bien!
Pensad que casi toda África pertenecía al
Imperio francés o el británico.
India, Pakistán y Bangladesh eran colonias
Británicas.
Casi toda Indonesia pertenecía a Países
Bajos.
Y la lista continúa.
Es decir, eran territorios gobernados por
una metrópoli.
Los ciudadanos de esos lugares no tenían
nada que decir sobre cómo se gobernaban.
Podríamos decir que vivían en una dictadura.
Y normalmente, vivían mal.
Como os podéis imaginar, la mayoría de las
élites políticas o económicas en un país
como Argelia, por poner un ejemplo, eran franceses.
Los argelinos nativos poco disfrutaban de
pertenecer al Imperio Francés.
Así que en el año 1960, la Unión Soviética
llegó a la ONU y dijo “esto tiene que terminar,
los imperios coloniales son cosa del pasado”.
Así es como se creó el Consejo para la descolonización
de la ONU.
Y ya sé lo que pensará alguno “Consejo
de la ONU” suena a muchos funcionarios,
muchas declaraciones donde dicen que están
“deeply concerned” y poco más ¿Verdad?
¡Pues nada de eso!
Los años 60 son los años de la descolonización.
En poco tiempo, casi todas las antiguas colonias
en África y en Asia se independizaron de
sus metrópolis.
Según la ONU, hoy en día sólo quedan 11
territorios sin autogobierno ¡Pero tranquilos!
En esta lista encontramos lugares como GIBRALTAR.
En fin…
creo que muchos de vosotros estaríais encantados
de vivir ahí, sobre todo después de haber
visto los vídeos que hemos hecho aquí en
VisualPolitik.
Y por si alguno se lo estaba preguntando:
NO.
Ni las islas Canarias ni Baleares están en
la lista Y diréis ¿Por qué?
Pues porque los ciudadanos de Canarias son
tan españoles como cualquier otro.
Votan en las elecciones igual que alguien
de Madrid o de Sevilla y tienen los mismos
derechos y obligaciones.
Ahora bien…
¿De verdad esta lista está completa?
Pensadlo bien: fue la Unión Soviética quien
propuso crear un comité de descolonización
pero…
¿Y si los Soviéticos también fueron un
imperio colonial?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(¿POR QUÉ RUSIA ES TAN GRANDE?)
Vuelvo a la pregunta del principio ¿Por qué
Rusia es tan grande?
Ya os digo que en el siglo 16, Rusia era mucho
más pequeña.
Atentos a este mapa.
Sin embargo, por estas fechas es cuando el
ZAR Iván “El Terrible” inició su expansión
hacia el este.
Como os podéis imaginar, hablamos de zonas
donde prácticamente nadie podría vivir.
Por ejemplo, en esta época es cuando se empieza
a colonizar SIBERIA, que no es precisamente
el paraíso.
Ahora bien, por estas tierras había tribus
y pueblos nómadas.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, a Ivan “El
terrible” le llamaban “El terrible”
por algo.
Sin embargo, el gran colonizador de nuestra
historia fue Pedro “El Grande”.
Llamado así porque fue el que agrandó el
Imperio Ruso hasta lo que conocemos hoy en
día.
Por cierto, que a mí siempre me ha parecido
fascinante que en aquella época, sin tecnología
ni nada parecido pudieran colonizar toda Siberia.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de Siberia!
El imperio Ruso se extendía a muchas zonas
que sí estaban habitadas.
Desde el Cáucaso hasta parte de Polonia o
incluso lo que hoy es Ucrania.
Y así es como llegamos al año 1917.
¿Y qué pasa ese año?
Seguramente esta parte de la historia rusa
la conozcáis todos ¡Exacto!
Es el año de la revolución bolchevique!
El marxismo clásico dice que las naciones
no son importantes.
Que el sentimiento nacional es un invento
burgués.
Acordaos del famoso “Proletarios del mundo
¡Uníos!”.
Fuera fronteras, todos somos iguales ante
el paraguas del clase obrera.
Sin embargo ¿Y qué se encontraron los comunistas
cuando llegaron al poder?
Pues se dieron cuenta de que Rusia era mucha
Rusia.
Por ejemplo, en la zona de Kalmukia o Buriatia
tenían tribus chamánicas y budistas.
En Georgia hablaban un idioma rarísimo que
tenía hasta su propia grafía ¡Ponte tu
a extender la dictadura del proletariado en
semejante torre de Babel!
Sin embargo, no os preocupéis: los bolcheviques
habían hecho sus deberes.
Para aquel entonces, el señor Josef Stalin
ya había escrito un libro muy interesante
titulado “Marxismo y Cuestión Nacional”.
Pensadlo bien: Stalin había nacido en Georgia.
Es decir, que venía de una zona que había
sido colonizada por Rusia.
Como diríamos hoy en día, Stalin tenía
una enorme sensibilidad por las minorías
étnicas.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¡¿STALIN!?
¿Estamos hablando del mismo Stalin de las
purgas, el hipercentralismo y los gulags?
Pues sí, el mismo.
La vida da muchas vueltas pero de eso vamos
a hablar más tarde.
Lo cierto es que en 1917 Stalin defendía
la autonomía regional.
Es decir, que cada pueblo dentro de Rusia
pudiera hablar su idioma y tener sus propios
gobiernos.
Por supuesto, todos ellos debían formar parte
del mismo partido comunista.
Es decir, en lo que a relaciones de clase,
todos los proletarios tenían que dejar sus
fronteras nacionales aparte.
Pero fuera del mundo del trabajo, el propio
Stalin reconocía el derecho a mantener la
cultura propia.
Y así es como nació la llamada…
(atentos que ahora viene una palabrota buena…)
“KORENIZATSIYA” que era una política
para promover a gente local en puestos de
administración.
Incluso llegaron a crear los llamados (atentos
que ahora viene otra palabrota aún peor)
NATSSOVIETY que eran consejos para representar
a las minorías étnicas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el propio Stalin
llegó a abrir escuelas donde se enseñaba
ucraniano.
Esto puede parecer muy normal hoy en día.
Pero era todo un cambio de mentalidad.
Para el ruso medio no era fácil asumir que
el resto de etnias tenían derecho a usar
su lengua y mantener su cultura.
Durante siglos, los zares habían intentado
imponer el ruso y la religión ortodoxa con
calzador en todos los territorios que conquistaban.
Sin embargo, Stalin tenía muy claro que no
se podía reconstruir un país sin dar poder
a las regiones.
Incluso llegaron a sacar políticas de discriminación
positiva para promover las lenguas locales
por encima del ruso.
En otras palabras, que Stalin podría mandar
a disidentes al gulag sin pestañear, pero
en lo que a sensibilidad con otras naciones
se refiere, parecía un hippie abraza árboles.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la Constitución
de 1936 reconoce que Rusia tiene: once regiones,
veintidós repúblicas autónomas, nueve regiones
autónomas y nueve territorios nacionales
¡Ojo!
Porque esta estructura territorial es muy
parecida a la actual.
Dentro de la propia Rusia existen repúblicas
independientes como, por ejemplo Chechenia.
Pero eso es otra historia.
¿El problema con todo esto?
Pues que para mediados de los años 30, la
población rusa empieza a enfadarse.
En muchos casos, la discriminación positiva
dejaba a los rusoparlantes en una situación
muy mala.
Dentro del propio partido comunista empezaron
a existir grandes debates.
Y para 1938, a Stalin no le quedó otro remedio
que decretar el Ruso como idioma obligatorio
en toda la unión soviética.
Durante las próximas décadas, toda esa sensibilidad
con distintas naciones que conforman el crisol
cultural socialista que era la Unión Soviética…
desapareció.
De hecho, para el año 1980, prácticamente
todas las posiciones del Politburó estaban
ocupadas por rusos.
Sin embargo…
Todo esto es lo que ocurría dentro de la
Unión Soviética.
Ahora vamos a ver lo que ocurría fuera.
Y creedme, si esto no tiene, al menos, tintes
claros de colonialismo, entonces yo soy Santa
Claus.
(EL PACTO DE VARSOVIA)
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial, Estados Unidos,
Reino Unido y Francia se reparten Europa junto
con la Unión Soviética ¿Qué criterio usaron
para repartirse Europa?
Pues en muchos casos, arbitrariedad pura y
dura.
En muchos casos, los soviéticos se quedaron
con países enteros simplemente porque llegaron
antes que los británicos o los americanos.
Y así es como la Unión Soviética creó
un área de influencia que incluía países
como POLONIA, la antigua CHECOSLOVAQUIA y
HUNGRíA.
De la noche a la mañana, estos países pasaron
a tener sistemas comunistas.
Y diréis ¿Pero cómo funciona esto?
Es decir…
¿De repente, en Hungría decidieron votar
al partido comunista en masa?
Pues lo cierto es que no.
Por ejemplo, Hungría celebró elecciones
en 1945.
Justo después de haber sido liberados por
los soviéticos, que mantenían su presencia
militar.
En estas elecciones, el partido comunista
sacó poco más del 17% del voto.
Pero los soldados soviéticos se encargaron
de intimidar a los políticos de la oposición.
Y, poco a poco, los comunistas fueron haciéndose
con todo el poder.
Diez años más tarde, en 1956, se produce
la Revolución Húngara.
Es decir, que muchos húngaros anticomunistas
se levantaron en armas contra el gobierno
comunista.
Pero desde Moscú se encargaron de sofocar
la revuelta.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando!
¡Era la guerra fría!
Todos cometieron excesos.
Pues sí y no.
A estas alturas, nadie puede negar que Estados
Unidos también intervino en un montón de
países para evitar que se crearan gobiernos
comunistas.
Pero, como en todo en esta vida, hay grados.
La CIA ha movido hilos en todo el mundo para
evitar el auge del comunismo.
Esto es cierto.
Pero también es cierto que en plena guerra
fría, en los años 80, Francia llegó a tener
un gobierno de coalición entre socialistas
y comunistas.
Y nadie envió los tanques a París para evitarlo.
Dicho de otra forma: una cosa son movimientos
en la sombra, espionaje y propaganda y otra
muy distinta es una invasión en toda regla.
Y diréis ¿De verdad la Unión Soviética
invadió algún país?
Pues sí.
Y esto nos lleva a hablar de la PRIMAVERA
de PRAGA.
La historia de cómo los comunistas llegaron
al poder en Checoslovaquia daría para un
vídeo en sí misma.
Ya os aviso que incluye asesinatos a políticos
tirándoles por la ventana, o como dirían
los soviéticos (((HACER GESTO DE COMILLAS
CON LOS DEDOS))) “suicidios”.
Pero eso es otra historia.
Porque después de 20 años de comunismo en
Checoslovaquia, el Gobierno de esta país
decidió dar un pequeño cambio de rumbo.
Hablamos del llamado “socialismo con rostro
humano” o, como lo llamó la prensa de entonces,
la “primavera de Praga”.
El por entonces presidente checoslovaco, Alexander
Dubček, quería reformar el socialismo.
Por ejemplo, proponía legalizar el multipartidismo
o permitir libertad de expresión.
Es decir, podríamos decir que buscaba algo
parecido a una socialdemocracia ¿Y qué hicieron
desde Moscú?
Pues veréis, el 20 de agosto de 1968, la
Unión Soviética mandó 200.000 tropas y
2000 tanques.
En unos pocos días, toda Checoslovaquia estaba
bajo el control absoluto soviético.
No sé si sois conscientes de lo que hablamos.
Pero entre 1968 y 1989, toda Checoslovaquia,
es decir, la actual Chequia y Eslovaquia,
tenían cerradas las fronteras.
Miles de familias quedaron rotas para siempre.
Y el Gobierno del país quedó completamente
en manos de Moscú.
A fin de cuentas, cualquier ligero desencuentro
con el Politburó significaría una nueva
invasión.
Dicho de otra forma: tanto Hungría como Checoslovaquia
o, incluso, Polonia, tuvieron gobiernos independientes
sólo en nombre.
No tenían libertad para convocar elecciones,
ni tampoco para poder sacar sus propias leyes.
Y la pregunta es ¿Hasta qué punto no se
podrían considerar colonias?
Y no sólo hablamos de Europa.
Los mismos ejemplos se pueden encontrar en
todos los países de Asia Central.
Desde Kazajistán hasta Mongolia.
El caso de Mongolia es especialmente llamativo.
Tradicionalmente, los mongoles han tenido
más lazos con los chinos que con los rusos.
Sin embargo, la influencia soviética llegó
hasta tal punto que incluso cambiaron su grafía
por el cirílico.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¿Qué tiene
que ver todo esto con la Rusia actual?
Todo el mundo sabe que la Unión Soviética
se desintegró en 1990.
Desde entonces, todos esos países que, en
su día, formaron parte de la URSS son naciones
independientes.
La pregunta es ¿De verdad lo son?
Dejando a un lado el conflicto de Ucrania,
tenemos muchos más ejemplos: desde la guerra
de Georgia en 2008 hasta la intervención
en Kazajistán este mismo año.
Y ahí es donde llega la gran pregunta que
dejamos en el video ¿Hasta qué punto podemos
entender a Rusia como un gran imperio colonial
que se resiste a desaparecer?
¿Y si el conflicto de Ucrania fuera un episodio
más de un imperio que se resigna a caer?
¿Qué impacto puede tener esto a nivel diplomático?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.